Is it me or do you have a good ear? Maybe it's just an impression, but the song likes to relax the sound of people who talk to you about super captivating topics for hours. It sounds good, because I have something really interesting for you. The first mobility service by subscription to the country offered by the mobile audience. Yes, of course. At Star, you can subscribe to your 5G forfeiture without being attached. Mobile audience.
是我听错了吗，还是你的听力很好？也许这只是错觉，但歌曲喜欢让那些为你讲述数小时迷人话题的人的声音变得轻松。这听起来不错，因为我有一些非常有趣的事情要告诉你。移动受众提供的全国首个订阅制移动服务。是的，当然。在 Star，你可以订阅你的 5G 套餐而无需绑定。移动受众。
To you, the difference. Or on our website. Winding around South Africa's eastern Cape Coastline is Marine Drive, a road that leads to some of the most popular beaches in Kabeha, known in the 1990s as Port Elizabeth. West of the city, Marine Drive extends into the rural outskirts where buildings are scarce. On one side of the road is the ocean, on the other is low, sprawling bushland. At 2.30am on Sunday, December 18, 1994,
对你来说，这就是区别。或者访问我们的网站。蜿蜒在南非东开普海岸线的是海滨大道（Marine Drive），这条路通往卡贝哈（Kabeha，20 世纪 90 年代被称为伊丽莎白港）一些最受欢迎的海滩。在城市以西，海滨大道延伸至建筑稀少的乡村郊区。道路的一侧是海洋，另一侧是低矮、蔓延的灌木丛。1994 年 12 月 18 日，星期日凌晨 2 点 30 分，
two cars abruptly stopped along this dark and lonely stretch of Marine Drive, one vehicle in front of the other. Each driver had slammed on their respective brakes before their passengers scrambled out to observe what lay before them. Illuminated by the car's high beams was a woman covered in dirt and dust, lying face down in the middle of the road. She was completely naked except for a denim shirt that was bunched around her stomach. A large pool of blood had formed beneath her head,
两辆车突然停在这段黑暗而孤独的海滨大道上，一前一后。每位司机都在乘客冲下车观察眼前景象之前猛踩了刹车。在汽车远光灯的照耀下，一个女人浑身沾满泥土和灰尘，面朝下躺在路中间。她全身赤裸，只有一件牛仔衬衫团在肚子周围。她头下形成了一大滩血迹，
the cause of which soon became clear. Her neck had been slashed from ear to ear. Music Just over an hour and a half earlier, a yellow Renault had pulled into a free parking space on Deer Street in Cabera's central neighbourhood. Inside the Renault was a 27-year-old woman with long, dark hair. She lived in an apartment a short distance away, but as her usual parking spot right out the front of her building wasn't available,
原因很快就清楚了。她的脖子从一只耳朵被割到了另一只耳朵。音乐。一个半小时前，一辆黄色雷诺车驶入了卡贝哈中心街区鹿街（Deer Street）的一个免费停车位。雷诺车里坐着一位 27 岁、留着长长黑发的女性。她住在不远处的一间公寓里，但由于她平时停车的建筑前没有空位，
she was forced to drive further on to find another. The street was dark and quiet as she turned off her car's engine and headlights before reaching over to the passenger seat to scoop up a pile of clean laundry. All of a sudden, the driver's side door swung open. A man leaned into the car and held a long, thin knife to the woman's throat. He was in his mid-20s and was skinny and tall with long hair. In a hushed voice he said, Move over or I'll kill you.
她被迫继续开车寻找另一个车位。当她关掉引擎和车灯，伸手去拿副驾驶座上的一堆干净衣物时，街道又黑又静。突然，驾驶座的车门被猛地推开。一个男人探身进车，用一把又长又细的刀抵住女人的喉咙。他 20 多岁，身材瘦高，留着长发。他压低声音说：“挪过去，否则我就杀了你。”
The woman did as ordered, sliding across to the passenger seat with the laundry bundled in her arms. The knife-wielding man followed behind, climbing into the driver's seat and turning the key in the ignition to start up the car. Don't worry, I don't want to hurt you. I just want to use your car for an hour, he told the terrified woman. Then he asked, What's your name? Susan, the woman answered. The man gave his own name in response.
女人照做了，怀里抱着衣物滑向副驾驶座。持刀男子紧随其后，爬上驾驶座，转动钥匙发动了汽车。“别担心，我不想伤害你。我只是想借你的车用一个小时，”他告诉那个惊恐的女人。然后他问：“你叫什么名字？”“苏珊，”女人回答。男人也报出了自己的名字作为回应。
Clinton Susan asked to be released, explaining that her boyfriend was waiting for her at home and telling Clinton he could take the car without her. No, Clinton replied. I want company. I have to find this friend of mine who stole my TV and he owes me money. They drove in silence for several minutes towards Main Street where the city was still at buzz with nightlife. Clinton pulled up near a nightclub named Club Tonight. Patrons were spilling out onto the street where cabs were lined up ready to take them home.
“克林顿。”苏珊请求被释放，解释说她的男朋友正在家里等她，并告诉克林顿他可以把车开走，放她离开。“不，”克林顿回答。“我需要陪伴。我得找到那个偷了我电视机还欠我钱的朋友。”他们沉默地开了几分钟，朝仍然沉浸在夜生活中的主街（Main Street）驶去。克林顿在一家名为“今晚俱乐部”（Club Tonight）的夜总会附近停下。顾客们涌向街头，那里停着准备送他们回家的出租车。
As Clinton stared at the crowd, he grew increasingly irritated. Eventually, he pulled away. He proceeded to drive up and down Main Street and several other side roads until he finally spotted a man. Clinton brought the Renault to a stop and the man walked over and clambered into the vehicle's back seat. Meet my friend Susan, Clinton said, before introducing the man he'd picked up. This is Tianz. Clinton headed south towards Summerstrand, an area home to a stretch of beaches popular with locals and tourists alike. All three of the car's occupants sat in silence as he drove slowly.
当克林顿盯着人群时，他变得越来越烦躁。最终，他开车离开了。他沿着主街和其他几条侧路来回行驶，直到终于发现了一个男人。克林顿停下雷诺车，那人走过来爬进了车的后座。“见见我的朋友苏珊，”克林顿在介绍他刚接上的人之前说道。“这是蒂安兹（Tianz）。”克林顿向南驶向萨默斯特兰德（Summerstrand），那里有一片深受当地人和游客欢迎的海滩。车里的三个人在缓慢行驶中保持沉默。
Soon, they were at the city's outer limits in a seaside town called North Hook. The last of the buildings and streetlights gave way to a dark road bordered by trees and shrubs. Clinton kept driving until they reached a sizeable clearing in the foliage. He drove off the road through the clearing onto some sand that led to the beach. Clinton kept manoeuvring the car until they were on more solid ground at a site where campfires had previously been burned and rubbish was left scattered about. There were beer cans, empty wine gardens and smashed bottles everywhere. Clinton parked the car, then asked Susan how to turn off its lights. She switched them off while Tianz got out of the back seat to take a walk around outside.
很快，他们到了城市边缘一个叫北钩（North Hook）的海滨小镇。最后的建筑和路灯让位于一条两旁长满树木和灌木的黑暗道路。克林顿一直开到树丛中一片相当大的空地。他驶离道路，穿过空地，开上通往海滩的沙地。克林顿继续操纵汽车，直到他们到达更坚实的地面，那里曾有人烧过篝火，垃圾散落一地。到处都是啤酒罐、空酒瓶和破碎的玻璃瓶。克林顿停下车，然后问苏珊怎么关掉车灯。她关掉灯，而蒂安兹从后座下来，在外面走动。
As Susan and Clinton sat alone in the Renault, she asked him, Now what? Clinton turned to face her and said, I thought you would have realized we want sex. Susan said she hadn't and Clinton asked if she was going to put up a fight. Susan paused, then replied, No. After raping Susan, Clinton called Tianz back to the car. Then Tianz raped Susan as well.
当苏珊和克林顿独自坐在雷诺车里时，她问他：“现在怎么办？”克林顿转过身面对她说：“我以为你会意识到我们想要性。”苏珊说她没意识到，克林顿问她是否打算反抗。苏珊停顿了一下，然后回答：“不。”强奸苏珊后，克林顿叫蒂安兹回到车里。然后蒂安兹也强奸了苏珊。
Afterwards, Clinton remarked, If we take you into town now, you are going to go to the police. Susan insisted that she wouldn't, but Clinton said he didn't believe her. He forced Susan to remove some rings she was wearing and Tianz promptly slid them onto his own fingers. The two men then taunted Susan, telling her that they would leave her in the isolated area naked and alone. One asked, What do you think old Nick would want us to do with her? The other replied, I think he wants us to kill her. In a swift movement, Clinton leapt on top of Susan and began to strangle her. When she begged him not to kill her, Clinton said sorry while continuing to choke her.
事后，克林顿评论道：“如果我们现在带你进城，你肯定会去报警。”苏珊坚持说她不会，但克林顿说他不相信她。他强迫苏珊摘下她戴的一些戒指，蒂安兹立刻把它们滑到了自己的手指上。这两个男人随后嘲弄苏珊，告诉她他们会把她赤身裸体地留在荒凉的地方。一个问：“你觉得老尼克（Old Nick）会想让我们怎么处置她？”另一个回答：“我想他想让我们杀了她。”克林顿迅速扑到苏珊身上开始掐她的脖子。当她恳求他不要杀她时，克林顿一边说对不起，一边继续掐她。
Susan lost consciousness and the two men dragged her body from the vehicle onto the ground below. Tianz asked Clinton if she was dead. Let's find out, he replied. He began to repeatedly stab Susan's abdomen with the knife he'd threatened her with earlier, until part of her small intestine was protruding from the wound. Susan let out a slight rasping sound and Tianz sprang into action, using a larger knife he was carrying to slash at her neck. Clinton soon pushed his accomplice aside and took over, cutting and slashing at Susan's throat over and over until her head was almost severed from her neck. The two men then rummaged through Susan's laundry and other personal belongings looking for anything of value. Finding little they cared for, they tossed most of it over her body. Then they got into her Renault and drove away.
苏珊失去了知觉，两个男人把她的身体从车里拖到地上。蒂安兹问克林顿她死了没有。“我们看看，”他回答。他开始用之前威胁她的刀反复刺向苏珊的腹部，直到她的小肠从伤口中突出。苏珊发出轻微的喘息声，蒂安兹立即行动，用他携带的一把更大的刀割向她的脖子。克林顿很快推开同伙接手，反复切割苏珊的喉咙，直到她的头几乎从脖子上断掉。两个男人随后翻找苏珊的衣物和其他个人物品，寻找任何有价值的东西。没找到什么感兴趣的，他们把大部分东西扔在她的尸体上。然后他们坐上她的雷诺车开走了。
The attack marked a murderous shift in an already violent spree that was being committed by the nautical gripper rapist. Ten months earlier in February of 1994, a 20-year-old student was sitting in a car observing a pizzeria in Caberra's central neighbourhood. Rachel, not her real name, had borrowed the car from her mother to drive to the takeaway restaurant as she had a job to do. She worked part-time for another local pizzeria and her employers had tasked her with spying on the rival restaurant to see how many customers went in and the amount of pizzas they ordered. They wanted to know what their competition's trade was like. Rachel took out a pen and paper to make a note each time somebody walked inside. She hadn't been there long when a man appeared by the driver's side window. He was white, skinny and rather tall, with light blonde hair and a thin face. In one hand, he held a pistol.
这次袭击标志着“航海抓捕强奸犯”（nautical gripper rapist）正在进行的暴力狂欢中出现了一次谋杀性的转变。十个月前的 1994 年 2 月，一名 20 岁的学生坐在车里观察卡贝哈中心街区的一家披萨店。瑞秋（化名）从她母亲那里借了车，开车去那家外卖店，因为她有一项工作要做。她在另一家当地披萨店兼职，雇主派她去监视竞争对手的餐厅，看看有多少顾客进去，以及他们点了多少披萨。他们想知道竞争对手的生意如何。瑞秋拿出纸笔，每当有人走进去就做个记录。她没待多久，一个男人就出现在驾驶座车窗旁。他是个白人，身材瘦高，有着浅金色的头发和一张瘦削的脸。他手里拿着一把手枪。
The man yanked open the car door and demanded Rachel move over to the passenger seat. Terrified, she did as she was told. The man took her place behind the wheel and began to drive. He took Rachel out of the city, heading south and then west along the coastline. After about 20 minutes, when they reached the town of Northook, the man stopped and parked the car. He sexually assaulted Rachel, then raped her. Afterwards, he drove her to a nearby roadhouse where he bought her a sandwich and a rose. The man chatted to Rachel in an intimate manner as though they were romantically involved. Then he raped her again. The ordeal lasted about three hours, after which the man drove Rachel back to the city. As he exited the car, he told her that she was an amazing person. He hoped she would let him, quote, make it up to her sometime.
男人猛地拉开车门，要求瑞秋挪到副驾驶座。惊恐万分，她照做了。男人坐到驾驶座上开始开车。他把瑞秋带出城，向南行驶，然后沿着海岸线向西。大约 20 分钟后，当他们到达北钩镇时，男人停下车。他性侵了瑞秋，然后强奸了她。事后，他开车带她去附近的一家路边餐馆，给她买了一个三明治和一朵玫瑰花。男人以亲密的态度与瑞秋聊天，仿佛他们正在谈恋爱。然后他又强奸了她一次。整个折磨持续了大约三个小时，之后男人开车把瑞秋送回了城里。当他下车时，他告诉她，她是一个了不起的人。他希望她能让他，引用他的话，“找个机会补偿她”。
Then, he disappeared into the night. Rachel managed to get herself back home but was too scared and traumatized to tell her parents what had happened. It would take her a week before she was able to speak of the abduction and rapes to a friend who encouraged her to go to the police. It didn't take long for investigators to track down Rachel's alleged rapist. Franz Dutoy was a truck driver and married father of one with another baby on the way. At 26 years old, he had a troubled past and this wasn't his first brush with the law. Although Rachel was able to identify Dutoy as her assailant after seeing his mugshot, by the time she came forward, it was too late to put together a rape kit. Dutoy was still charged but because there was no forensic evidence available and he had a steady job as well as a fixed address where he lived with his wife, the laws of the time dictated that he must be released on bail.
然后，他消失在夜色中。瑞秋设法回到了家，但因为太害怕和受创伤，不敢告诉父母发生了什么事。过了一周，她才能够向一位朋友讲述绑架和强奸的事，朋友鼓励她去报警。调查人员没花多久就找到了瑞秋所谓的强奸犯。弗朗茨·杜托伊（Franz Dutoy）是一名卡车司机，已婚，有一个孩子，另一个孩子即将出生。26 岁的他有着坎坷的过去，这并不是他第一次触犯法律。虽然瑞秋在看到他的入案照片后能够认出杜托伊就是袭击者，但当她站出来时，收集强奸证据包已经太晚了。杜托伊仍然被起诉，但由于没有法医证据，而且他有一份稳定的工作以及与妻子同住的固定住所，当时的法律规定他必须被保释。
Months later, Franz Dutoy struck again. On the evening of Sunday, December 4, 1994, 21-year-old Caroline, not her real name, headed out to go to a corner store when Dutoy suddenly appeared out of nowhere. But this time he wasn't alone. With him was his neighbour and friend, 19-year-old Tianz Kruger. Dutoy and Kruger threatened Caroline with a handgun before abducting and raping her. They taunted the young woman, saying they would kill her and leave her body naked and abandoned. Caroline, who was pregnant and in her first trimester, begged them to let her live and they eventually took off into the night. Caroline quickly reported the attack to police.
几个月后，弗朗茨·杜托伊再次作案。1994 年 12 月 4 日，星期日晚上，21 岁的卡罗琳（化名）正要去一家便利店，杜托伊突然从天而降。但这次他不是一个人。和他在一起的是他的邻居兼朋友，19 岁的蒂安兹·克鲁格（Tianz Kruger）。杜托伊和克鲁格用手枪威胁卡罗琳，随后将她绑架并强奸。他们嘲弄这个年轻女子，说他们会杀了她，把她的尸体赤身裸体地丢弃。怀孕且处于孕早期阶段的卡罗琳恳求他们让她活下去，他们最终消失在夜色中。卡罗琳很快向警方报告了这次袭击。
Franz Dutoy and Tianz Kruger were promptly found and arrested. The two seemed entirely unfazed by the charges against them. Kruger considered the entire thing to be a big joke and even burst out laughing multiple times throughout the booking process. He and Dutoy both appeared in the magistrates court the following morning. It was so early in the investigation that a specific officer hadn't been assigned to handle the case yet. Even though this second attack took place in the same area where Dutoy had abducted Rachel, the two had been arrested by a different squad and taken to another police station. Due to this, the prosecutor who stood in the courtroom that day had no idea that Dutoy was already out on bail for a previous violent rape. This oversight meant that once again Franz Dutoy was granted bail and so was his younger accomplice.
弗朗茨·杜托伊和蒂安兹·克鲁格很快被找到并逮捕。两人对针对他们的指控似乎完全无动于衷。克鲁格认为整件事是个大笑话，甚至在整个登记过程中多次大笑。他和杜托伊第二天早上都出现在地方法院。调查还处于早期阶段，还没有指派专门的警官来处理此案。尽管第二次袭击发生在杜托伊绑架瑞秋的同一地区，但两人是被另一支小队逮捕并带到另一个警察局的。因此，那天站在法庭上的检察官根本不知道杜托伊因为之前的暴力强奸案已经在保释中。这种疏忽意味着弗朗茨·杜托伊再次获得了保释，他的年轻同伙也是如此。
Almost two weeks later on Saturday, December 17, Dutoy and Kruger were stalking their previous hunting ground of Central in search of another victim. Both men were buzzing after spending the afternoon getting through nine bottles of beer and a two and a half litre bottle of sherry. By the afternoon, their thoughts had turned once again to finding a woman to harm. Specifically, they sought a victim who was driving a nice car so they could steal it afterwards. At around 12.30pm, they spotted a woman who was in the process of parking her car. The two men approached the vehicle and Dutoy attempted to pull open the driver's side door. But he glanced away for a split second and the woman quickly managed to lock herself in. After realizing they wouldn't be able to abduct her, Dutoy and Kruger ran from the scene.
近两周后的 12 月 17 日，星期六，杜托伊和克鲁格正在他们之前的狩猎场——中心街区徘徊，寻找下一个受害者。两人在下午喝了九瓶啤酒和一瓶 2.5 升的雪利酒后，都处于兴奋状态。到了下午，他们的心思再次转向寻找一个可以伤害的女人。具体来说，他们寻找一个开着好车的受害者，这样他们事后可以偷走它。下午 12 点 30 分左右，他们发现一个女人正在停车。两个男人靠近车辆，杜托伊试图拉开驾驶座车门。但他分神了一秒钟，女人迅速设法把自己锁在车里。意识到无法绑架她后，杜托伊和克鲁格逃离了现场。
For hours they paced the city on the lookout for another target. When they couldn't find any, Kruger grew impatient and annoyed. He told Dutoy that he was going to head to a nightclub. If Dutoy managed to capture a suitable woman, he should come and find him later. Undeterred, Dutoy continued walking the streets, his eyes peeled for a woman alone in a vehicle. At around 1am, he headed along Deer Street, a quiet side road that ran through Central and was dotted with apartment buildings. Suddenly, he spotted a small yellow Renault pulling into a free parking space. Dutoy recognized the young woman driving.
他们花了几个小时在城里徘徊，寻找另一个目标。当找不到时，克鲁格变得不耐烦和恼火。他告诉杜托伊他要去一家夜总会。如果杜托伊能抓到一个合适的女人，他应该稍后再去找他。杜托伊没有气馁，继续在街上走着，眼睛盯着寻找独自在车里的女人。凌晨 1 点左右，他沿着鹿街走，这是一条穿过中心街区、点缀着公寓楼的安静侧路。突然，他发现一辆小型黄色雷诺车驶入一个免费停车位。杜托伊认出了开车的年轻女子。
He didn't know her name, but he had seen her many times before as he stalked the neighborhood, parking that same car and walking into a nearby apartment. Her vehicle was old and not what he'd been hoping for. Dutoy wanted to drive his victim back to North Hook, the same isolated location where he'd attacked Rachel earlier in the year. North Hook was a fair distance out of the city and the Renault looked as though it could break down at any moment. Still, Dutoy decided to strike. He made his way over to the Renault through the darkness. The street lamps were easy enough to avoid and numerous parked cars along the street provided cover. Dutoy reached the Renault's driver's side door just as the woman cut the engine and turned off the car's lights.
他不知道她的名字，但他以前在街区徘徊时多次见过她，停下那辆车，走进附近的一间公寓。她的车很旧，不是他所希望的那样。杜托伊想把受害者带回北钩，也就是他今年早些时候袭击瑞秋的那个偏僻地点。北钩离城市有一段距离，雷诺车看起来随时可能抛锚。尽管如此，杜托伊还是决定下手。他穿过黑暗走向雷诺车。路灯很容易避开，沿街停放的众多汽车提供了掩护。就在女人关掉引擎和车灯时，杜托伊到达了雷诺车的驾驶座车门旁。
Dutoy yanked open the driver's side door. This time, he was carrying a knife. Forcing his captive to slide over into the passenger seat, Dutoy got behind the wheel and drove off. He introduced himself using the fake name Clinton and she said her name was Susan. Dutoy headed to the nightclub that Tian's Kruger had intended to visit and eventually found him on a side street. Susan was driven out into the rural outskirts where both Dutoy and Kruger raped her. Afterwards, the pair emboldened each other to take the next step in their violent spree. They took turns stabbing Susan before cutting her throat multiple times to the point of near-decapitation. They drove back to the city in Susan's Renault.
杜托伊猛地拉开驾驶座车门。这一次，他带着一把刀。强迫俘虏滑到副驾驶座，杜托伊坐到驾驶座上开车离去。他用假名“克林顿”介绍了自己，她说她叫苏珊。杜托伊前往蒂安兹·克鲁格打算去的夜总会，最终在一条侧路上找到了他。苏珊被带到乡村郊区，杜托伊和克鲁格都在那里强奸了她。事后，两人互相怂恿，在暴力狂欢中迈出了下一步。他们轮流刺伤苏珊，然后多次割开她的喉咙，直到几乎斩首。他们开着苏珊的雷诺车回到了城里。
Neither spoke throughout the entire journey and Dutoy threw his knife into some bushes. Kruger kept his knife. They abandoned the Renault around the corner from Dutoy's apartment, then headed home to drink more beer and get some sleep. Dutoy and Kruger woke at around 11am excited by the thought that they'd committed murder. They wanted to claim another victim soon, but this time they would carry out their plot slightly differently. They would abduct and kill a woman, then throw her body off a bridge that Dutoy was familiar with. The pair chatted as they prepared their breakfast. Kruger used the same knife he had cut Susan's throat with to butter his bread.
整个旅程中没有人说话，杜托伊把他的刀扔进了灌木丛。克鲁格留下了他的刀。他们在杜托伊公寓的拐角处遗弃了雷诺车，然后回家喝更多的啤酒并睡觉。杜托伊和克鲁格在上午 11 点左右醒来，为他们犯下谋杀案的想法感到兴奋。他们想很快再找一个受害者，但这次他们会稍微不同地执行计划。他们会绑架并杀害一个女人，然后把她的尸体扔下杜托伊熟悉的一座桥。两人在准备早餐时聊天。克鲁格用他割开苏珊喉咙的那把刀涂抹面包。
Some of Susan's blood was still visible on the blade, which Kruger pointed out gleefully. Yet, their plans were interrupted the following day. At around 5am, there was a loud pounding on the front door of Dutoy's apartment. He and Kruger were both inside sleeping. When they answered the knocking, they saw two police officers standing outside. The officers made no mention of Susan or her murder, instead telling the pair they wanted to question them about a recent rape. A confident Dutoy and Kruger went without struggle. Dutoy and Kruger were placed into separate holding cells at the police headquarters,
刀刃上仍然可以看到一些苏珊的血迹，克鲁格幸灾乐祸地指了出来。然而，他们的计划在第二天被打断了。凌晨 5 点左右，杜托伊公寓的前门传来一阵剧烈的敲门声。他和克鲁格都在里面睡觉。当他们回应敲门声时，看到两名警察站在外面。警察没有提到苏珊或她的谋杀案，而是告诉两人他们想就最近的一起强奸案审问他们。自信的杜托伊和克鲁格没有反抗就去了。杜托伊和克鲁格被分别关进警察总部的拘留室，
and some time later, Melvin Humphill, a senior investigating officer, arrived to interview them. He decided to speak with Tian's Kruger first and escorted the younger suspect to his office. Humphill asked Kruger to take a seat. He appeared completely disinterested when the officer read him his rights. Then, Humphill informed Kruger that he was being investigated on two different charges, one of rape and one of attempted murder. Surprised, Kruger glanced up at the officer as he processed what he was saying and asked, Attempted murder? Why attempted murder? I have news for you, Melvin Humphill replied.
一段时间后，高级调查警官梅尔文·汉普希尔（Melvin Humphill）赶来审问他们。他决定先与蒂安兹·克鲁格谈话，并将这名年轻的嫌疑人带到了他的办公室。汉普希尔让克鲁格坐下。当警官宣读他的权利时，他显得完全不感兴趣。然后，汉普希尔通知克鲁格，他正在接受两项不同指控的调查，一项是强奸，一项是谋杀未遂。克鲁格惊讶地抬头看着警官，处理着他所说的话，问道：“谋杀未遂？为什么是谋杀未遂？”“我有消息要告诉你，”梅尔文·汉普希尔回答。
Your last victim survived. She's talking and remembers everything. At around 2.30am on Sunday, December 18, Tian Eilard drove his combivan along Marine Drive, following behind his friend's BMW. The two carloads of friends had just wrapped up a beach holiday with a visit to a nightclub and were heading back to the caravan park where they were camping. Suddenly, Tian's friend up ahead hit the brakes and came to a stop. Then he flicked on his car's hazard lights. As Tian slowed behind him, he wondered what had caused his friend to stop in the middle of the road. Perhaps there was an injured pedestrian or animal up ahead. Some of Tian's friends in the BMW got out and looked at something on the road in front of the car. One of them began screaming in terror and ran over to Tian's vehicle.
“你的最后一个受害者活下来了。她正在说话，记得一切。”12 月 18 日，星期日凌晨 2 点 30 分左右，蒂安·埃拉德（Tian Eilard）开着他的面包车沿着海滨大道行驶，跟在他朋友的宝马车后面。两车朋友刚结束海滩假期，去了一家夜总会，正准备回他们露营的房车公园。突然，前面蒂安的朋友踩了刹车并停了下来。然后他打开了车的危险警示灯。当蒂安在他身后减速时，他想知道是什么原因让他的朋友停在路中间。也许前面有受伤的行人或动物。宝马车里的一些蒂安的朋友下车，看着车前路上的东西。其中一个人惊恐地尖叫起来，跑向蒂安的车。
She told him that someone was hurt on the ground and Tian needed to help. As a veterinary science student, Tian had some knowledge of anatomy and medicine. He jumped out and ran over to the spot his friend indicated. The BMW's headlights had cast a spotlight on a dishevelled woman lying on the road, naked except for a denim shirt pressed to her abdomen. Her head was facing away from them and blood had pulled beneath it. Tian could hear the woman breathing in heavy gasps. Tian knelt beside the woman and took her hand. It wasn't until he was facing her that he saw the huge wound around the base of her neck near the collarbone.
她告诉他有人在地上受伤了，蒂安需要帮忙。作为一名兽医系学生，蒂安对解剖学和医学有一些了解。他跳下车，跑向朋友指出的地点。宝马车的车灯照亮了一个衣衫褴褛的女人，她躺在路上，除了压在腹部的一件牛仔衬衫外，全身赤裸。她的头背对着他们，血在下面汇聚。蒂安能听到女人沉重的喘息声。蒂安跪在女人身边，握住她的手。直到面对她时，他才看到她锁骨附近脖子根部的巨大伤口。
It was so deep and so wide that Tian could see the muscles and veins inside. Tian made eye contact with the woman, who looked terrified. He spoke to her in soothing tones as he checked her pulse and removed his shirt, then used it to apply gentle pressure to her neck wound. Her thyroid had also been cut in two and part of it was sticking out. Tian tucked it back inside the wound to keep it moist. The entire time he chatted with the woman, encouraging her to stay conscious, asking her what had happened and reassuring her that help was on the way. She was unable to speak so she communicated with Tian by squeezing his hand. Even though it was 1994, one of Tian's friends had a mobile phone and was able to call for an ambulance.
它又深又宽，蒂安可以看到里面的肌肉和静脉。蒂安与那个看起来惊恐万分的女人进行了眼神交流。他用安抚的语气与她交谈，同时检查她的脉搏并脱下自己的衬衫，然后用它对她的颈部伤口施加轻微的压力。她的甲状腺也被切成两半，一部分露在外面。蒂安把它塞回伤口里以保持湿润。整个过程中，他一直与女人聊天，鼓励她保持清醒，问她发生了什么事，并向她保证救援正在路上。她无法说话，所以通过握紧蒂安的手与他交流。尽管是 1994 年，蒂安的一位朋友还是有一部手机，并能够呼叫救护车。
It took more than two hours for it to finally arrive. Doctors and nurses at the hospital were alarmed to see the state that the woman was in. She had received more than 30 stab wounds to the abdomen and her throat was slashed 17 times. All of the main veins in her neck had been cut, along with the trachea, thyroid and anterior muscles. But she had survived because her attackers missed her main arteries. Her aorta and larynx were also undamaged, which was how she was still able to breathe. Extreme blood loss had put her in a state of shock that prevented her from feeling any pain. Despite her life-threatening injuries, she remained conscious and was even able to sign an intake form.
救护车花了两个多小时才最终到达。医院的医生和护士看到女人的状态感到震惊。她腹部受了 30 多处刀伤，喉咙被割了 17 次。她脖子上的所有主要静脉都被切断了，气管、甲状腺和前部肌肉也是如此。但她活了下来，因为袭击者错过了她的主要动脉。她的主动脉和喉部也没有受损，这就是她仍然能够呼吸的原因。极度失血使她处于休克状态，这使她感觉不到任何疼痛。尽管伤势危及生命，她仍然保持清醒，甚至能够签署入院表格。
Her name was Allison and she was 27 years old. Allison even managed to write down her mother's phone number so she could be contacted. A doctor performed emergency surgery, reconnecting Allison's muscles and stitching her neck back together. The wound to her abdomen had resulted in her entire small intestine becoming exposed. This organ had to be carefully and meticulously cleaned in saline solution as dirt, leaves and sand that had collected on it could cause infection. The doctor then stitched up cuts that the organ had received before putting it back inside Allison and closing up her second wound. By 8.35 am on Sunday December 18, 7.5 hours after Allison was abducted, her surgery was complete. The fact that Allison had survived her devastating injuries amazed hospital staff and law enforcement.
她的名字叫艾莉森（Allison），今年 27 岁。艾莉森甚至设法写下了她母亲的电话号码，以便联系她。医生进行了紧急手术，重新连接了艾莉森的肌肉并将她的脖子缝合在一起。腹部的伤口导致她整个小肠暴露在外。这个器官必须在生理盐水中小心细致地清洗，因为上面积聚的泥土、树叶和沙子可能会导致感染。医生随后缝合了器官受到的切口，然后将其放回艾莉森体内并缝合了她的第二个伤口。到 12 月 18 日星期日早上 8 点 35 分，即艾莉森被绑架 7.5 小时后，她的手术完成了。艾莉森在遭受毁灭性伤害后幸存下来的事实让医院工作人员和执法部门感到震惊。
But her incredible story of survival was shocking. Allison told police of her abduction at Knife Point as she sat in her car a short distance away from her apartment. She briefly considered opening the door and leaping out but felt frozen in place. Her abductor introduced himself as Clinton. Not wanting to tell him her real name, Allison told him she was called Susan. She also said that she had a boyfriend at home waiting for her, but this was a lie she hoped would compel her abductor to release her. Instead, he drove her into the city and also picked up a younger man named Tianz. He seemed angrier and more volatile than his older accomplice.
但她令人难以置信的生存故事令人震惊。艾莉森告诉警方，她在离公寓不远的地方坐在车里时被持刀绑架。她曾短暂考虑过打开车门跳出去，但感觉身体僵住了。她的绑架者自称是克林顿。不想告诉他真名，艾莉森告诉他她叫苏珊。她还说她家里有男朋友在等她，但这只是一个谎言，她希望这能迫使绑架者释放她。相反，他开车把她带进城里，还接上了一个名叫蒂安兹的年轻人。他看起来比他的年长同伙更愤怒、更不稳定。
Still, Allison was willing to believe the man just wanted the car. When Clinton announced that the pair intended to rape Allison, she knew her best chance of survival lay in not putting up a fight. Throughout the ordeal, Allison repeatedly told herself, he's doing this to your body but not to you. He can't touch you. At one stage, Tianz referred to Clinton as Franz, which Allison realized must be his real name. They also mentioned another person, Old Nick, but Allison knew that was a nickname for Satan. She made a mental note to remember her attackers' names while simultaneously reassuring them that she wouldn't go to the police. Franz and Tianz didn't believe her. Franz launched himself on Allison and began strangling her. She begged him not to kill her, and he apologized, but continued. Then, everything went dark.
尽管如此，艾莉森还是愿意相信男人只是想要这辆车。当克林顿宣布两人打算强奸艾莉森时，她知道她生存的最佳机会在于不反抗。在整个折磨过程中，艾莉森反复告诉自己：“他是在对你的身体做这件事，而不是对你。他碰不到你。”在某个阶段，蒂安兹称克林顿为弗朗茨，艾莉森意识到这一定是他的真名。他们还提到了另一个人，老尼克，但艾莉森知道那是撒旦的绰号。她暗自记下要记住袭击者的名字，同时向他们保证她不会报警。弗朗茨和蒂安兹不相信她。弗朗茨扑向艾莉森开始掐她。她恳求他不要杀她，他道歉了，但继续掐她。然后，一切都变黑了。
Allison lost consciousness. The next thing she knew, she was lying on the ground. Franz stood over her, his arm moving back and forth as he repeatedly cut her neck. Allison felt nothing but could hear the sound of the knife meeting her skin. Eventually, Franz stopped and walked away. Allison could hear him talking in a low voice with his accomplice. Despite the violent attack she'd endured, Allison felt extremely alert and aware of everything going on around her. When she heard a strange grumbling noise, she soon realized that was coming from her own throat. It was the sound of her breathing through her wound. Unable to control her breath, she stuck her hand inside the injury to muffle the noise and prevent Franz and Tianz from realizing she was still alive. Do you think she's dead, one of the men asked? No one can survive that, said the other confidently. Then they got into her car and drove away.
艾莉森失去了知觉。她醒来时发现自己躺在地上。弗朗茨站在她上方，手臂来回移动，反复割着她的脖子。艾莉森什么也没感觉到，但能听到刀子碰到皮肤的声音。最终，弗朗茨停下来走开了。艾莉森能听到他与同伙低声交谈。尽管遭受了暴力袭击，艾莉森感到非常清醒，意识到周围发生的一切。当她听到一种奇怪的隆隆声时，她很快意识到那是从她自己的喉咙里发出的。那是她通过伤口呼吸的声音。无法控制呼吸，她把手伸进伤口以掩盖声音，防止弗朗茨和蒂安兹意识到她还活着。“你觉得她死了吗？”其中一个男人问。“没有人能活下来，”另一个人自信地说。然后他们坐上她的车开走了。
Convinced that she would die, Allison was determined to leave a final message behind. She used a finger to write the names Franz and Tianz in the sand. Beneath that, she traced the words, I love mum. Allison then began to feel as though she were floating out of her own body and hovering above it. She could look down and see herself crumpled and bleeding on the ground, but she felt light and peaceful. Despite what had been done to her, Allison felt a soothing presence and knew she was being asked a crucial question. Did she want to return to her body and fight? Realizing there was still so much she wanted to do with her life, Allison knew that she did. A moment later, she was back in her body. Allison forced herself up onto her hands and knees.
确信自己会死，艾莉森决心留下最后的信息。她用手指在沙子上写下了弗朗茨和蒂安兹的名字。在下面，她写下了“我爱妈妈”。艾莉森随后开始感到仿佛正从自己的身体里飘出来，悬浮在上方。她可以向下看，看到自己蜷缩在地上流血，但她感到轻松和平静。尽管遭受了这一切，艾莉森感到一种抚慰的存在，并知道她被问了一个关键问题。她想回到身体里去战斗吗？意识到她的人生还有很多想做的事情，艾莉森知道她想。片刻之后，她回到了自己的身体里。艾莉森强迫自己用手和膝盖支撑起来。
Feeling something wet and slippery on her abdomen, she looked down and realized that she had been stabbed there as well. Some of her intestines had fallen out of the wound. Allison couldn't hold them in as they kept slipping out of her arms, so she found a denim shirt that her attackers had thrown on the ground. Allison wrapped the shirt around her intestines and held it against her body. Slowly she began to crawl along the ground towards the road they had driven in from. Allison still felt no pain. Her knees and hands suffered cuts from the broken glass on the ground, and her head felt wobbly and unstable due to the repeated cuts to her neck. After crawling about 15 meters into a clearing, Allison collapsed.
感觉到腹部有湿滑的东西，她低头一看，意识到自己也被刺伤了。她的一些肠子从伤口里掉了出来。艾莉森无法抓住它们，因为它们不断从她怀里滑落，所以她找到了袭击者扔在地上的牛仔衬衫。艾莉森把衬衫裹在肠子上，紧贴着身体。她慢慢地开始沿着他们开进来的路爬行。艾莉森仍然没有感到疼痛。她的膝盖和手被地上的碎玻璃割伤，由于脖子上的反复切割，她的头感觉摇摇晃晃、不稳定。爬行了大约 15 米进入一片空地后，艾莉森倒下了。
Driven by the thought of how devastated her loved ones would be if she died, she forced herself to keep moving. Allison tried to stand, realizing that walking would be faster than crawling. But when she did, the gaping wound to her neck caused her head to tip backwards until it nearly touched her shoulder blades. With one hand still clutching the shirt to her abdomen, she used the other hand to pull her head forwards. Then she began walking. Sometimes she tripped over, but she would always force herself up again. Allison stumbled through the bush and vegetation until she finally spotted Marine Drive, the wide road they had driven in from. She found a spot in the middle of the road where she would be visible to any passing motorists and lay down there.
想到如果她死了，亲人会多么悲痛，她强迫自己继续前进。艾莉森试图站起来，意识到走路比爬行快。但当她这样做时，脖子上巨大的伤口导致她的头向后倾斜，直到几乎碰到肩胛骨。一只手仍然紧紧抓住腹部的衬衫，她用另一只手把头向前拉。然后她开始走路。有时她会被绊倒，但她总是强迫自己再次站起来。艾莉森跌跌撞撞地穿过灌木丛和植被，直到终于看到了他们开进来的宽阔道路——海滨大道。她在路中间找了一个任何过往司机都能看到她的地方，躺了下来。
After a little while, she heard a car approaching, though she couldn't see it as her face was turned the other way. As it drew nearer to Allison, it slowed down to a stop, its headlights shining brightly on her. Allison waved urgently, but no one got out of the vehicle. After what felt like a long time, the car was put into drive again and swerved around Allison's body before continuing on and disappearing into the darkness. Allison felt as though she had just lost her last chance of survival. Until Tiana Eilard and his friends happened upon her as they drove along Marine Drive towards the Caravan Park where they were staying. When news of the attack and Allison's seemingly miraculous survival made newspaper headlines, flowers and gifts flooded in from all over South Africa. Police sprang into action upon being notified of the rape and attempted murder.
过了一会儿，她听到一辆车驶近，但她看不见它，因为她的脸转向了另一边。当它靠近艾莉森时，它减速停了下来，车灯明亮地照在她身上。艾莉森急切地挥手，但没有人下车。在感觉过了很长时间后，车子再次启动，绕过艾莉森的身体，继续行驶并消失在黑暗中。艾莉森觉得她刚刚失去了最后生存的机会。直到蒂安·埃拉德和他的朋友们开车沿着海滨大道前往他们居住的房车公园时偶然发现了她。当袭击和艾莉森看似奇迹般的生存消息登上报纸头条时，鲜花和礼物从南非各地涌来。警方在接到强奸和谋杀未遂的通知后立即采取了行动。
Nadia Swannapool was a young officer familiar with Franz Dutoy and Tiana Kruger and knew the two were out on bail for raping another young woman just two weeks earlier. Suspecting that Dutoy and his younger accomplice could be behind Allison's attack, Officer Swannapool headed to the hospital on Sunday December 18 armed with a photo album full of mug shots. She flicked through the pages showing Allison hundreds of different photographs of various suspects. When Officer Swannapool reached one particular page, Allison's eyes were immediately drawn to a headshot near the bottom. She recognized the man featured instantly. It was Franz Dutoy. The following morning at 5am, Officer Swannapool and her partner arrested both men at Dutoy's apartment. Once Dutoy and Kruger were in custody, senior investigating officer Melvin Humple was caught upon to interrogate them. He decided to speak to 19-year-old Kruger first.
纳迪亚·斯旺纳普尔（Nadia Swannapool）是一位年轻的警官，熟悉弗朗茨·杜托伊和蒂安兹·克鲁格，并知道两人两周前因强奸另一名年轻女子而处于保释期。怀疑杜托伊和他的年轻同伙可能是艾莉森袭击案的幕后黑手，斯旺纳普尔警官于 12 月 18 日星期日带着一本装满入案照片的相册前往医院。她翻阅着页面，向艾莉森展示了数百张不同嫌疑人的照片。当斯旺纳普尔警官翻到特定的一页时，艾莉森的目光立刻被底部附近的一张头像吸引住了。她立刻认出了照片中的男人。那是弗朗茨·杜托伊。第二天早上 5 点，斯旺纳普尔警官和她的搭档在杜托伊的公寓逮捕了两人。一旦杜托伊和克鲁格被拘留，高级调查警官梅尔文·汉普希尔就被叫来审问他们。他决定先与 19 岁的克鲁格谈话。
The two sat in Melvin Humple's office. Kruger looked bored as the detective read him his rights, but his demeanor changed entirely when he heard that Allison had survived and remembered everything. Visibly terrified, he said, oh fuck, then it won't even help if I lie. Kruger pulled some rings he was wearing off his fingers, dropped them on the detective's desk and stated, there, here are her rings. Then, he began to talk. Tian's Kruger's life had always been difficult. He was raised by his mother and his abusive stepfather in the town of Sundriff. As a child, Kruger often ran away from his troubled home and sought solace in the town's black community, which was kind to him. South Africa was still under apartheid at the time, and some of the local white residents were angry at Kruger for mixing with the black population.
两人坐在梅尔文·汉普希尔的办公室里。当侦探宣读他的权利时，克鲁格看起来很无聊，但当他听说艾莉森活了下来并记得一切时，他的态度完全变了。他明显很害怕，说：“哦，该死，那就算我撒谎也没用了。”克鲁格从手指上摘下他戴的一些戒指，扔在侦探的桌子上，说道：“给，这是她的戒指。”然后，他开始说话。蒂安兹·克鲁格的生活一直很艰难。他在桑德里夫（Sundriff）镇由母亲和虐待他的继父抚养长大。小时候，克鲁格经常从他那麻烦不断的家里逃出来，在镇上的黑人社区寻求慰藉，那里的人对他很友善。当时南非仍处于种族隔离制度下，一些当地白人居民对克鲁格与黑人混在一起感到愤怒。
He was ostracized by them as a result. Kruger eventually left school to join the army. He later said that in 1993, while completing his national service, he was called to deal with a riot. Kruger claimed that when a woman involved in the riot swore at the police, he'd responded by shooting her in the head. In 1994, Kruger began working as a security guard and moved in with his aunt in Kabeha. He said he was disappointed that he hadn't died during his army service, as one of his friends had, and during a botched suicide attempt, he accidentally shot himself in the foot with a rifle. It was while he was recovering from this injury that he met Franz Dutoy. Dutoy's life was one with little direction or purpose. Like Kruger, he had served in the military during his youth and spent a year and a half fighting on the country's border with Namibia, which was then under South African administration. After Dutoy's service was up, his father, who was a policeman, found him a job at a mine.
结果他被他们排斥了。克鲁格最终离开学校参军。他后来声称，1993 年在完成国民服役期间，他被叫去处理一场骚乱。克鲁格声称，当一名参与骚乱的妇女对警察咒骂时，他以射击她的头部作为回应。1994 年，克鲁格开始担任保安，并搬到卡贝哈与他的阿姨同住。他说他很失望自己在服兵役期间没有像他的一个朋友那样死去，在一次拙劣的自杀企图中，他用步枪意外射伤了自己的脚。正是在他从这次伤势中恢复期间，他遇到了弗朗茨·杜托伊。杜托伊的生活缺乏方向或目标。像克鲁格一样，他在年轻时曾在军队服役，并在该国与纳米比亚（当时由南非管理）的边境战斗了一年半。杜托伊服役结束后，身为警察的父亲为他在矿场找了一份工作。
Dutoy only worked there briefly, before moving on again. By the 1990s, Dutoy was living a transient lifestyle, moving from city to city and working menial jobs. He wound up in Kabeha, where he married his second wife in 1993. She was in the early stages of pregnancy when Dutoy abducted and raped Rachel in February of 1994. Four months later, Dutoy met Tian's Kruger when the teenager started purchasing booze from an unlicensed venue Dutoy ran. Soon they were drinking together regularly and bonding over common ground. As Kruger confided in Dutoy about his struggles, Dutoy offered his young friend an alternative path. He claimed that although he had been raised by parents who devoutly practiced Christianity, he had discovered another faith during his adolescence.
杜托伊在那里只工作了很短时间，然后又离开了。到了 20 世纪 90 年代，杜托伊过着漂泊的生活，从一个城市搬到另一个城市，做着卑微的工作。他最终来到卡贝哈，并于 1993 年与第二任妻子结婚。当杜托伊在 1994 年 2 月绑架并强奸瑞秋时，她正处于怀孕早期。四个月后，当这个少年开始从杜托伊经营的一个无证场所购买酒水时，杜托伊遇到了蒂安兹·克鲁格。很快他们就开始经常一起喝酒，并因共同点而建立起联系。当克鲁格向杜托伊倾诉他的挣扎时，杜托伊为他的年轻朋友提供了一条替代道路。他声称，尽管他是由虔诚的基督徒父母抚养长大的，但在青春期期间他发现了另一种信仰。
It all started when he fell into our quote, bad crowd, kids who he said were cannabis-smoking hippies and surfers. Then, Dutoy started listening to heavy metal music, which he would later say held subliminal messages. When he burnt down a building, he blamed his actions on the messages he'd absorbed through the music. This incident led to Dutoy's expulsion from school and he was soon enrolled in another one. One day, he was sitting on a train when he met a young woman who also attended his new school. Supposedly, she was the head witch of a local coven and Dutoy believed she had supernatural powers. He insisted that he had witnessed her channeled demons and that as they spoke through her, her voice changed from being feminine to one that was deep and masculine. Dutoy said he began to put faith in these supposed demons.
这一切始于他陷入了所谓的“坏圈子”，即他所说的吸食大麻的嬉皮士和冲浪者。然后，杜托伊开始听重金属音乐，他后来称这些音乐包含潜意识信息。当他烧毁一栋建筑时，他把自己的行为归咎于他通过音乐吸收的信息。这件事导致杜托伊被学校开除，他很快又被另一所学校录取。有一天，他坐在火车上时遇到了一位也上他新学校的年轻女子。据称，她是当地一个女巫团的头目，杜托伊相信她拥有超自然力量。他坚持说他曾目睹她引导恶魔，当恶魔通过她说话时，她的声音从女性变成了深沉的男性声音。杜托伊说他开始相信这些所谓的恶魔。
Dutoy introduced Tian's Kruger to his beliefs, telling him he was part of a notorious Satanist group that met regularly under a nearby bridge. This bridge was infamous in Kibbehar as a place where people would go to take their own lives. When Dutoy told Kruger about the power of demons, Kruger said that he would like some of that power for himself. Dutoy then nicknamed his younger companion Damien, a nod to the antagonist in the film The Omen, who is characterized as the son of Satan. The pair began heading out on midnight trips to visit St. Mary Cemetery, the city's oldest graveyard. They would steal statues from graves and burn black candles, often while drunk and high. Sometimes they were joined by others. On one occasion, Kruger was teased by the rest of the group who said he would never desecrate a grave.
杜托伊向田的克鲁格介绍了他的信仰，告诉他自己是一个臭名昭著的撒旦教团体的成员，该团体定期在附近的一座桥下聚会。这座桥在基贝哈尔臭名昭著，是人们去自杀的地方。当杜托伊告诉克鲁格关于恶魔的力量时，克鲁格说他自己也想要一些那种力量。杜托伊随后给他的年轻同伴起了个绰号叫达米安，这是向电影《凶兆》中的反派致敬，该角色被刻画为撒旦之子。两人开始在午夜前往圣玛丽公墓，那是该市最古老的墓地。他们会从坟墓上偷走雕像并点燃黑色蜡烛，通常是在喝醉和吸毒的状态下。有时其他人也会加入他们。有一次，克鲁格被小组里的其他人嘲笑，说他永远不敢亵渎坟墓。
He responded by taking a hammer and smashing a headstone, while swearing at the person who was buried below. Kruger despised most other people. He had no respect for anyone, especially those who tried to, quote, force religion down my throat. He sought escape through drugs and alcohol, and took to walking the streets late at night as a way to calm down. Dutoy joined him one night in early December, and the pair carried out their first rape together. Kruger would later say that he felt nothing throughout this entire attack. Dutoy initially intended to make good on his threat to murder the woman, but he's urged to kill a baited after he raped her. Two weeks later, he wouldn't be as merciful towards Alison. Tian's Kruger gave a detailed confession about the attack he and his accomplice had inflicted on Alison.
他回应的方式是拿起一把锤子砸碎了一块墓碑，同时对着埋在下面的人破口大骂。克鲁格鄙视大多数人。他不尊重任何人，尤其是那些试图“强行向我灌输宗教”的人。他试图通过毒品和酒精来逃避，并开始在深夜走上街头以求平静。十二月初的一个晚上，杜托伊加入了他的行列，两人一起实施了他们的第一次强奸。克鲁格后来声称，在整个袭击过程中他没有任何感觉。杜托伊最初打算兑现他杀死这名女子的威胁，但在强奸她之后，他被怂恿去杀害一个诱饵。两周后，他对艾莉森就不会那么仁慈了。田的克鲁格详细供述了他和同伙对艾莉森实施的袭击。
When it was Franz Dutoy's turn to be interviewed, he was similarly stunned to learn that Alison was alive. That's impossible, she couldn't have survived, he said. A moment later, he spoke in a calm voice. Well then, I have to tell the whole truth. His confession confirmed everything that Kruger had admitted to. Neither man showed any sign of remorse. They were charged for Alison's rape and attempted murder. This time, they didn't receive bail. Friends of Alison's, including her boss and some ex-boyfriends, gathered at the magistrates' court to be present for the men's first appearance.
当轮到弗朗茨·杜托伊接受审讯时，他同样震惊地得知艾莉森还活着。他说，这不可能，她不可能活下来。片刻之后，他平静地说，既然如此，我必须说出全部真相。他的供词证实了克鲁格所承认的一切。两人都没有表现出任何悔意。他们因强奸和企图谋杀艾莉森而被起诉。这一次，他们没有获得保释。艾莉森的朋友们，包括她的老板和几位前男友，聚集在治安法庭，出席了这两名男子的首次出庭。
They shouted abuse as Dutoy and Kruger were led back to their cells, and one newspaper later reported that Dutoy had looked terrified during the altercation. The South African public was outraged by the horrific case. The country's rate of sexual violence ranked as one of the highest in the world, but rarely did a victim's ordeal become so public. The brutal nature of Alison's injuries and her survival against all the odds meant that her story made headlines across the nation. Journalists rang Alison and her mother constantly, hoping for an interview. Police discouraged Alison from going public in case it compromised the case, but she was eager to speak out. Eventually, once Alison was well enough to return home, she was permitted to give one reporter from the eastern province Herald a brief interview about her ongoing recovery. She also wrote an open letter that was published in the paper.
当杜托伊和克鲁格被带回牢房时，他们大声辱骂，后来一家报纸报道说，杜托伊在争执中显得惊恐万分。南非公众对这起骇人听闻的案件感到愤怒。该国的性暴力发生率位居世界前列，但受害者的苦难很少如此公开。艾莉森伤势的残酷性以及她在绝境中的幸存，使得她的故事登上了全国各地的头条新闻。记者们不断地给艾莉森和她的母亲打电话，希望能进行采访。警方劝阻艾莉森公开露面，以免影响案件审理，但她渴望说出真相。最终，当艾莉森身体状况好转可以回家时，她获准接受了东部省先驱报一位记者的简短采访，谈论她正在进行的康复情况。她还写了一封公开信，发表在报纸上。
In it, Alison thanked everyone who had helped her for their care and support. Each one who sent flowers, gifts, cards, wishes, thoughts, prayers and love should know how they brought a smile to my face and an added warmth to my heart. I have life. Beautiful people. You have my heart. Alison's father also wrote a letter to the editor of the eastern province Herald, which was published in full on the paper's front page. He was devastated by what had happened to his daughter, and he openly criticized the country's bail laws that had allowed two violent predators to walk free and attack further victims. Before the trial against Franz Dutoy and Tiana Kruger could proceed to court, Alison was required to identify them both in person. Because the city's small police station did not have a room with a one-way mirror, Alison was told she would have to enter the room where the line-up was taking place and identify her attackers by placing her hand on their shoulders. The thought of having to do this terrified Alison. She refused to take part under those guidelines, and so a compromise was struck.
在信中，艾莉森感谢了所有给予她关怀和支持的人。每一个送来鲜花、礼物、卡片、祝福、思念、祈祷和爱的人，都应该知道你们是如何让我脸上重现笑容，让我的内心倍感温暖。我活下来了。善良的人们，你们拥有我的心。艾莉森的父亲也给《东部省先驱报》的编辑写了一封信，并全文刊登在报纸的头版。他对女儿遭遇的不幸感到悲痛欲绝，并公开批评了该国的保释法，正是这些法律让两名暴力掠食者逍遥法外，并继续伤害其他受害者。在针对弗朗茨·杜托伊和蒂安·克鲁格的审判开始前，艾莉森必须亲自指认他们。由于该市的小警察局没有单向玻璃的房间，艾莉森被告知她必须进入列队指认的房间，并通过把手放在袭击者肩上来指认他们。想到要这样做，艾莉森感到恐惧。她拒绝在这些准则下参与，因此双方达成了一个折中方案。
The line-up would take place in one of the station's smaller offices, which had a one-way petition. Alison would still have to stand in the same room as her attackers, but she would be partly hidden from them and wouldn't have to touch them. On Friday, March 3, 1995, almost three months after the attack, Alison made her way to the police station. She immediately picked out Dutoy and Kruger from a row of 14 men. Although both men had agreed to plead guilty, there would still be a trial with extensive witness testimony to determine their sentences. The men's police statements made their way to the media, and the fact that they blamed Satanism for leading them to commit their crimes had already been splashed across tabloid newspapers. The press dubbed them the nautical gripper rapists after the isolated location where they attacked Alison and another victim. One week before proceedings began, Franz Dutoy called a press conference at police headquarters, despite still being held on remand.
列队指认将在警察局的一间较小的办公室进行，那里有一个单向隔断。艾莉森仍然必须和袭击者站在同一个房间里，但她会被部分遮挡，不必触碰他们。1995年3月3日星期五，即袭击发生近三个月后，艾莉森前往警察局。她一眼就从14名男子的队列中认出了杜托伊和克鲁格。尽管两人都同意认罪，但仍需进行审判，并听取大量的证人证词以确定刑期。这些人的警方供词被媒体曝光，他们将犯罪归咎于撒旦崇拜的事实已经在小报上大肆渲染。媒体将他们称为“航海抓捕强奸犯”，因为他们袭击艾莉森和其他受害者的地点非常偏僻。在诉讼程序开始前一周，尽管弗朗茨·杜托伊仍被还押候审，但他还是在警察总部召开了新闻发布会。
The conference was allowed to go forward, and Dutoy told attending journalists how he was officially renouncing his Satanic beliefs. He blamed his criminal behaviour on demonic possession and said he would undergo an exorcism prior to the trial. This announcement was treated as a publicity stunt by most people, including Dutoy's victims. The trial began on Monday, June 12, 1995. The woman who the men had tried to abduct almost 12 hours before they took Alison gave evidence, as did all three women who had been raped by them. The second victim, Caroline, had been in the early stages of pregnancy when she was attacked on December 4, 1994, and was almost at full term as she spoke in court. Dutoy and Kruger both testified in their own defence. They told the court of their troubled backgrounds and how they came to practice what they called Satanism. Dutoy claimed that since he was 15, he'd been possessed by a demon called Incubus, which made him irresistible to women.
发布会如期举行，杜托伊告诉在场的记者，他正式放弃自己的撒旦信仰。他将自己的犯罪行为归咎于恶魔附身，并表示在审判前会进行驱魔仪式。大多数人，包括杜托伊的受害者，都将这一声明视为一场公关噱头。审判于1995年6月12日星期一正式开始。在他们带走艾莉森前近12小时试图绑架的那名女子出庭作证，三名被他们强奸的女性也出庭作证。第二名受害者卡罗琳在1994年12月4日遇袭时正处于怀孕初期，她在法庭上发言时已接近预产期。杜托伊和克鲁格都为自己进行了辩护。他们向法庭讲述了自己坎坷的背景，以及他们是如何开始实践所谓的撒旦崇拜的。杜托伊声称，从15岁起，他就被一个名叫“梦魇”的恶魔附身，这使他让女性无法抗拒。
He blamed Incubus for the rapes he had committed. Dutoy's wife Natalie was standing by her husband and attended court to support him. He attributed her loyalty to a spell he had cast, asking that she would never have the power to leave him. In 1992, the South African Police Service had established an occult-related crimes unit, due to the Satanic panic that was then sweeping the country. The Satanic panic was a moral panic that spread around the world during the late 20th century, but was particularly influential in South Africa, where belief in the occult was strong. An officer from the occult-related crimes unit spoke at the trial, refuting Dutoy's claims of demonic possession. He said Dutoy's clear recollection of his crimes meant he was entirely in control of his own actions. The officer also claimed that if Dutoy had been possessed, he would have raped his wife as well, but he hadn't.
他将自己犯下的强奸罪归咎于“梦魇”。杜托伊的妻子娜塔莉站在丈夫一边，并出庭支持他。他将妻子的忠诚归功于他施下的咒语，要求她永远没有离开他的能力。1992年，南非警察局成立了一个专门处理邪教相关犯罪的部门，以应对当时席卷全国的“撒旦恐慌”。“撒旦恐慌”是20世纪末在全球范围内蔓延的一种道德恐慌，但在南非尤为严重，因为那里对神秘学的信仰根深蒂固。邪教犯罪部门的一名警官在审判中发言，驳斥了杜托伊关于恶魔附身的说法。他说，杜托伊对自己罪行的清晰回忆意味着他完全能够控制自己的行为。该警官还声称，如果杜托伊真的被附身，他也会强奸自己的妻子，但他并没有这样做。
While Dutoy seemed to enjoy the limelight and his newfound notoriety, Tian's Kruger was quieter. A clinical psychologist who had examined Kruger determined that the 19-year-old had borderline personality disorder and suffered from extremely low self-esteem. Franz Dutoy and Tian's Kruger were ultimately convicted of two counts of rape, two charges of indecent assault, two counts of abduction, attempted murder, and theft. During sentencing, the judge dismissed Dutoy's claims of demonic possession and sentenced him to three terms of life imprisonment. Kruger was given one count of life imprisonment for the crimes against Allison, plus 25 years for the second rape. The judge made it clear that while Kruger may have been influenced by his older accomplice, he still exhibited disturbing bloodlust. The judge concluded with one final decree, quote, I also make the following order.
虽然杜托伊似乎很享受聚光灯和新获得的恶名，但蒂安·克鲁格则安静得多。一名为克鲁格做过检查的临床心理学家确定，这名19岁的年轻人患有边缘性人格障碍，且自尊心极低。弗朗茨·杜托伊和蒂安·克鲁格最终被判犯有两项强奸罪、两项猥亵罪、两项绑架罪、谋杀未遂罪和盗窃罪。在量刑时，法官驳回了杜托伊关于恶魔附身的说法，判处他三次终身监禁。克鲁格因对艾莉森的罪行被判处一次终身监禁，外加因第二起强奸案被判25年监禁。法官明确表示，虽然克鲁格可能受到了他年长同伙的影响，但他仍然表现出了令人不安的嗜血本性。法官最后做出了最后的一项裁决，引用如下：“我还做出以下命令。”
It must be clear that if at any time in the future there is any consideration for parole, it was my intention that these two men be removed from society for the rest of their natural lives, and that they should spend it behind bars. Cheers echoed through the courtroom in response to the judge's words. As Dutoy and Kruger were being escorted out, Kruger slammed his hand against the wall and shouted, Here we go. Fuck you all. With both men convicted and sentenced, Allison was free to speak publicly about her ordeal. She was eager to do so in the hopes that her words might inspire other women who had been raped to come forward. Allison knew that many rape survivors were left with a feeling of shame and wanted to make it clear that they had nothing to be ashamed of. Allison gave an exclusive interview to a magazine titled You and also spoke on air with a local radio presenter.
必须明确的是，如果未来任何时候考虑假释，我的意图是让这两个人余生都与社会隔绝，在监狱中度过。法庭上回荡着对法官这番话的欢呼声。当杜托伊和克鲁格被押送出去时，克鲁格猛地拍了一下墙壁，大喊道：走着瞧。去你们的。随着两人被定罪判刑，艾莉森终于可以公开谈论她的遭遇了。她渴望这样做，希望自己的话能激励其他被强奸的女性勇敢站出来。艾莉森知道，许多强奸幸存者都背负着羞耻感，她想明确表示，她们没有什么可羞耻的。艾莉森接受了《You》杂志的独家采访，并与当地的一位电台主持人进行了连线。
When the male presenter told her he felt honored to speak with a rape survivor as he had never done so before, Allison responded, You don't know that. So many women are silent about it. At the same time that she was publicly advocating for survivors of rape, Allison was also going through a gruelling recovery. Even as her physical wounds began to heal, she was left with significant scarring that required reconstructive and plastic surgery. Too scared to return to the apartment where she'd been living at the time of the attack, Allison moved to a new one in a more secure complex. She also struggled with focusing at work and soon sank into a deep depression. One day, Allison received an invitation to give a talk about her experiences at a rotary club. Although public speaking made her nervous, she decided to accept the offer.
当男主持人告诉她，他很荣幸能与一位强奸幸存者交谈，因为他以前从未这样做过时，艾莉森回答说：你不知道这一点。有太多的女性对此保持沉默。在公开为强奸幸存者倡导的同时，艾莉森也正在经历一段极其痛苦的康复过程。即使她的身体伤口开始愈合，她仍留下了严重的疤痕，需要进行重建和整形手术。由于害怕回到袭击发生时居住的公寓，艾莉森搬到了一个安保设施更好的新公寓。她还难以集中精力工作，很快陷入了深深的抑郁之中。一天，艾莉森收到邀请，去扶轮社讲述她的经历。尽管公开演讲让她感到紧张，但她还是决定接受邀请。
To her surprise, the talk went well. Soon she was accepting more opportunities to speak at other events. Allison found that speaking publicly about her attack helped her come to terms with it. Because she had to tell audiences what she had learnt through it all, she began to reflect more deeply on how she had survived. Encouraged by the positive feedback she received from those who attended her talks, Allison eventually embarked on a career as a motivational speaker. She won multiple awards for her bravery and would wind up travelling all over the world to share her story. When she married, she took her husband's surname of Buerta and became known by this name in the media. Allison also worked with author Marianne Tham to write a book about her experiences. It was published in 1998 under the title I Have Life.
令她惊讶的是，演讲进行得很顺利。很快，她接受了更多在其他活动中演讲的机会。艾莉森发现，公开谈论她的袭击经历有助于她接受这一切。因为她必须告诉听众她从中领悟到了什么，她开始更深刻地反思自己是如何幸存下来的。在听众给予的积极反馈的鼓励下，艾莉森最终开启了励志演说家的职业生涯。她因勇敢而赢得了多个奖项，并最终前往世界各地分享她的故事。结婚后，她随了丈夫的姓氏布尔塔，并以这个名字在媒体上为人所知。艾莉森还与作家玛丽安·塔姆合作写了一本关于她经历的书。该书于1998年以《我拥有生命》为题出版。
In 2011, new legislation came into force in South Africa, which meant all prisoners who had been given life sentences prior to 2004 could apply for parole, providing they had already served at least 13 years and 4 months. Franz Dutoy and Tianz Kruger both fell under this category. The two applied for parole. Kruger appeared before his prison's parole board in December 2011 and was said to have boasted to fellow inmates that he would soon be free. Dutoy had his hearing the following month. Authorities did not notify Allison or the pair's other victims of this development and they were left to learn about the man's possible release via the media.
2011年，南非实施了新立法，这意味着所有在2004年之前被判终身监禁的囚犯，只要已经服刑至少13年零4个月，就可以申请假释。弗朗茨·杜托伊和蒂安兹·克鲁格都属于这一类。两人都申请了假释。克鲁格于2011年12月出现在监狱假释委员会面前，据称他向狱友吹嘘自己很快就会重获自由。杜托伊在次月进行了听证会。当局没有通知艾莉森或这两人的其他受害者这一进展，他们只能通过媒体得知这两人可能获释的消息。
Allison was devastated. She believed that the judge's order at sentencing meant her attackers would never be freed. To her relief, neither man was given parole, but they were still permitted to reapply for it every two years. In August of 2015, Allison, who was now 47 years old, received a strange email from an American woman named Joyce. She was getting in touch with Allison because she was worried about her daughter Sabrina, who was 34. According to Joyce, Sabrina was engaged to Franz Dutoy, now aged 46, and wanted to travel to South Africa to help him with his next parole application. The pair had met via Facebook and communicated entirely online. Sabrina hadn't initially known that Dutoy was in prison.
艾莉森感到崩溃。她认为法官在判刑时的命令意味着她的袭击者永远不会被释放。令她欣慰的是，两人都没有获得假释，但他们仍被允许每两年重新申请一次。2015年8月，当时47岁的艾莉森收到了一位名叫乔伊斯的美国女性发来的奇怪邮件。她联系艾莉森是因为她担心自己34岁的女儿萨布丽娜。据乔伊斯说，萨布丽娜与现年46岁的弗朗茨·杜托伊订了婚，并想去南非帮助他进行下一次假释申请。两人通过Facebook相识，完全在网上交流。萨布丽娜起初并不知道杜托伊在坐牢。
When he told her what he was serving time for, Dutoy admitted to being a rapist but claimed he had no part in trying to kill Allison. That attack was entirely the fault of his accomplice, Tianz Kruger. He also said that the prison authorities were pleased with his progress and believed he was a changed man. When Sabrina's mother, Joyce, found out about the relationship, she contacted South Africa's Department of Correctional Services, but received no response. So she decided to reach out to Dutoy's soul-named victim, Allison Buerta. Joyce attached page after page of correspondence between Sabrina and Dutoy, which she'd obtained from her daughter's Facebook account. In his writings to Sabrina, Dutoy claimed that he'd organized for a woman to be raped after she accused him of killing her father. He'd also had another woman gang-raped by some men he called his boys.
当他告诉她他因何入狱时，杜托伊承认自己是强奸犯，但声称他没有参与谋杀艾莉森的企图。那次袭击完全是他同伙蒂安兹·克鲁格的错。他还说，监狱当局对他的表现很满意，认为他已经改过自新。当萨布丽娜的母亲乔伊斯发现这段关系时，她联系了南非惩教署，但没有得到回应。于是她决定联系杜托伊的受害者艾莉森·布尔塔。乔伊斯附上了萨布丽娜和杜托伊之间的大量通信记录，这些记录是她从女儿的Facebook账户中获取的。在写给萨布丽娜的信中，杜托伊声称他曾组织人强奸了一名指控他杀害其父亲的女性。他还让其他女性被他称之为“我的男孩们”的一群人轮奸。
Dutoy said he'd done all of this from behind bars. He made threats against people he wanted to harm when he was released and asked Sabrina for money. Dutoy also bragged about how he'd bribed prison officials into letting him have access to mobile phones. Allison was horrified and couldn't believe Dutoy was being allowed access to social media. She emailed a complaint to prison authorities who in turn forwarded it to Dutoy. Angered by the lack of regard being shown for her personal safety, Allison went to the media for help. Despite articles being published in the magazine You and Other Publications, Dutoy was still allowed to maintain multiple Facebook accounts. When Franz Dutoy heard that a South African film director named Uga Carlini was making a feature documentary about the attack against Allison and her survival,
杜托伊说，这一切都是他在狱中完成的。他威胁要伤害那些他出狱后想报复的人，并向萨布丽娜要钱。杜托伊还吹嘘自己如何贿赂监狱官员，让他们允许他使用手机。艾莉森感到震惊，无法相信杜托伊竟然被允许使用社交媒体。她向监狱当局发送了投诉邮件，当局随后将其转发给了杜托伊。由于对个人安全缺乏重视感到愤怒，艾莉森向媒体寻求帮助。尽管《You》杂志和其他出版物发表了相关文章，但杜托伊仍然被允许保留多个Facebook账户。当弗朗茨·杜托伊听说南非电影导演乌加·卡里尼正在制作一部关于艾莉森遇袭及其幸存经历的纪录片时，
he reached out and offered to be interviewed. But he made it clear that he had some conditions. First, he wanted a signed letter from Allison Werther saying that she had forgiven him. And second, he demanded a backdated share of the profits from Allison's motivational speaking career and book sales as he said she owed all of her success to his actions. Uga Carlini refused Dutoy's request. Her documentary titled Allison was released in 2016. Allison Werther's life wasn't the only one changed by what happened to her on December 17, 1994. Tiana Eilard, the man who helped save Allison by providing first aid, was so affected by the incident that he decided to become a doctor instead of a vet.
他主动联系并提出接受采访。但他明确表示自己有一些条件。首先，他想要一封艾莉森·布尔塔签署的信，说明她已经原谅了他。其次，他要求获得艾莉森励志演讲生涯和书籍销售利润的追溯分成，因为他说她的成功全归功于他的行为。乌加·卡里尼拒绝了杜托伊的要求。她的纪录片《艾莉森》于2016年上映。艾莉森·布尔塔的生活并不是1994年12月17日发生的事情中唯一被改变的。通过提供急救帮助挽救艾莉森的蒂安娜·埃拉德，深受此事影响，决定成为一名医生而不是兽医。
He and Allison have remained close throughout the years and in November 2006, when Allison gave birth to her second child, Tiana assisted with the delivery. Becoming a mother felt like a miracle to Allison. She was worried that she would never be able to have children due to the injuries she sustained during the attack, but she now has two sons. After Allison Werther's two attackers were convicted, she was given a small cardboard box filled with evidence that police had gathered from the crime scene. It contained her clothing and other personal belongings that had been dumped on the ground. For a long time, Allison kept the box at the back of a cupboard and refused to look inside. But a few years later, while working on her book with author Marianne Timm, she decided to do something with it. As described in the book I Have Life, Allison, Marianne and Allison's husband took the box back to the location where Allison was almost killed.
多年来，他和艾莉森一直保持着密切联系。2006年11月，当艾莉森生下第二个孩子时，蒂安娜协助了分娩。对艾莉森来说，成为母亲感觉就像一个奇迹。她曾担心由于袭击中受到的伤害，自己可能永远无法生育，但她现在有两个儿子。在艾莉森·布尔塔的两名袭击者被定罪后，她收到了一个装满警察从犯罪现场收集的证据的小纸箱。里面装着她的衣服和其他被扔在地上的个人物品。很长一段时间里，艾莉森把这个盒子放在橱柜后面，拒绝看里面的东西。但几年后，在与作家玛丽安·蒂姆合作写书时，她决定处理一下这些东西。正如书《我拥有生命》中所述，艾莉森、玛丽安和艾莉森的丈夫把盒子带回了艾莉森差点丧命的地方。
They went late at night so that the area looked exactly as Allison remembered it. She removed the bloodstained garments and other items then piled them on the ground. With her husband's help, Allison set fire to the belongings. As she watched them burn and then eventually saw the flames die out, Allison felt a sense of relief. Thanks for watching! There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
他们深夜前往，这样该地区看起来和艾莉森记忆中的一模一样。她取出沾满血迹的衣服和其他物品，然后堆在地上。在丈夫的帮助下，艾莉森点燃了这些物品。当她看着它们燃烧，最终看到火焰熄灭时，艾莉森感到了一种解脱。感谢观看！本集暂无评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。